今日のテーマ 自信過剰って何なのかということ
まあ自信過剰っていうのは自信がない人が被る鎧なんですよ
自信があって それが過剰になったわけじゃないんです
よく覚えてください 自信過剰な人にも全く自信がないんですよ
これが過剰という鎧でごまかしちゃうんです
自信がないから過剰になる
自信過剰症は敵が的が的が外れる人の中で発生する
これ病気ですよ 自信がないことも病気だと言いたいんだけど
まあその他大勢のみんな自信がないんだから
まあ病気というのは失礼だから
これはやめたんです やめて
自信過剰ということは病気ですと
あの的を外れるという現象から
この時間のずれじゃないんです
的外れるというところから過剰になるんです
時間ずれ症の場合はケースは少ない
時間ずれの人が自信過剰になるっていうことはあまりないんですよ
だから自信過剰な人はあんまり将来過去を妄想しない
だから将来に過去にずれてる人にとっては
もうそれだけでもうエネルギーがないんだから
もう自信がないだけで過剰にはならない
行動しないんです これで過去と現在のはずれない人がいて
今現在のことは見ているようなつもりですけど
その人が過剰になるんです
だから これはすごく微妙なポイントなんですけど
時間 自信過剰症っていうのは
時間的外れる人に起こる病気です
自信がないという不幸な状態をごまかしたいんですよ
過剰になったところで
自分も自分の弱さに気づかないし
もう過剰に行動しちゃうと
自分が弱いということに気づかないでごまかせますよ
他人も圧倒させて 抑えられます
もう厳しくテキパキと
もう行動するとみんな圧倒されちゃいますよ
だから何も言いませんね
本当に自信過剰な人にはブレーキかけること難しいでしょうね
もう言うこと聞かないし
言えないし あまりにも元気で頑張ってるんだから
これは一体あれほど元気でやってるんだから
あれほど苦労してるんだから
あれほど頑張ってるんだから
まあ言いにくいなとかね
まあ私にもそういう経験ありますよ
もう完全にお前バカやと言いたいんだけども
一生懸命やってるんだから
ちょっと社会的に言いづらいんですね
でも知ってます これはもう無知で過剰症やと
結果はゼロやとも知ってるんですけど
だからもう自分のもう迫力で行動力で他人まで抑えて言わせないようにする
それ自分でも気づかなくなっちゃうんです
だから自信過剰っていうのは鎧ですよ
自信のない人の自信過剰に欠かせないもの
自信過剰 病気にはこれこれこれが欠かせないんですよ
無知 自信過剰なら無知でやるということはもう明らかにはっきりするんです
無知でなきゃ自信過剰になりません
だから一番大きなポイントは無知っていうことなんです
なぜ無知かというと この因果法則っていうものは世の中にあります
現状 過程 結果などを 無視すればするほど過剰になりやすいんですよ
原因関係は無視するわ
現状状況は無視するわ
結果を過程も無視するわ
とにかくやる えらい元気
それが過剰になる原因ですよ
だから無知なんですよ
やってみなきゃわからないでしょうはモットーになってますね
考えるっていうことはないんです
もうバカのいいところでやってみなきゃわからないバカなんですよ
だから毒を飲んでみなきゃ死ぬかどうかわからないぞとかね
体に火をつけなかったら
もうもうもう これでもう火傷して死ぬかどうかわからないでしょうとかね
そんなもの話なんですよ
だからやってみなきゃわからないということは
とんでもないフレーズで
自信過剰な人は確実に無知です
自信がない人が無知に支配されているんだったら
もう過剰という病気を背負うんです
それで自信過剰の仲間がいるんです
もう主な原因は無知 無知さえあれば誰でも過剰になるんです
まだちょこっと仲間もいるんです
それも前も説明したんだから
あんまりもう早く言います
アビッジャ アヴィャーパーダ
前もそのポイントが出ました
異常な欲と怒りですね
これ仲間です 頭が悪い上にすっごい妄想的な欲があると何するか分からないんですよ
頭が悪い上上に妄想的な怒りがあるとどんなことをするか分からないんです
これ 2つは病気です 異常な 2つの病気の一つにかかると常識がなくなるので
狂ったような状態で物事にかかるんです
無知と異常な欲が一緒になると
もう狂ったように動くんですよ
あるいは無知と怒りが絡むと
もう自信過剰でもう何するか分からない
高慢も認めてほしいという慢も
自信過剰症を引き起こします
高慢があったり みんなに認めてほしいとかね
みんなに好かれたいとかね
そういう慢があるともうもう自信過剰になるんですけど
主な原因じゃない これは仲間です
こういうのはサポートするんです
次に 自信過剰の場合はマインドコントロールと自信過剰ということ
これから大事なポイントが来ますので
暗示やマインド マインドコントロールによっても
人は簡単に自信過剰症に陥る
本人は無知で怠けで理性がなく
言われる通りにやれば安心だという気持ちで
気が弱く 脅されやすい
安いか鵜呑みにしてしまう性格ならですよ
簡単にマインドコントロールされます
無知でなきゃそうね マインドコントロールできませんよ
怠けているんだったら
まあ別に簡単ですよ マインドコントロールする側にとっては素晴らしい条件です
これが  ローマ字で書いたのはちょっと長すぎですよ
カタカナだったら マインドコントロールは誰がするの？ということ
自分じゃないでしょうに
マインドコントロールというと他人です
まず親が子供にやっているんです
だから親から聞けばね
本当にいい子やっていうのは
そのマインドコントロールしやすい子供ですよ
マインドコントロールしにくい子供に対しては
もうこいつはもう何やってるかわからない
言うことを聞かないんだとかね
もう困って困ってしょうがないんですよ
でも子供はすごい元気なんですよ
ちっちゃい時から自立神経があって
もうとにかく自分でやりたい
何でもかんでも いくらしつけをしたっても
自分が理解していないとやらない
例えば知らない人は 自分にとってはもう機嫌あまり気に入らない人
知らない人に会ったら
親だったらちゃんと挨拶しなさいと言うでしょうね
子供はあっち向くでしょ
親が困るんですよ 言った通りにちゃんと受給しちゃうと
親がすごく舞い上がっちゃうんですね
いい子やと  そんなもんで
我々は知らず知らず子供たちをマインドコントロールする
それでマインドコントロールしやすい子は一番可愛いんですね
いい子ですよ 学校で教育者がするんですね
スポーツなどでコーチもやるんでしょ
それで仲間グループでリーダーがやるんですね
いろんなグループを作りますね
社会で我々は その場合は
そのグループのリーダーがマインドコントロールする
学校で でもやっぱりリーダーに選ぶ人はキャプテンに選ぶ人はね
影響力ある人なんですね
会社で上司がやるんですよ
まあ下手な人もいますけど
それから皆見事に期待通りに大失敗する
そうやってマインドコントロールされちゃって
うまくいかないんです
ものすごく親言うことだけ聞いて大きくなる子供っていうのは
全く一人前にならないんですよ
上司言う通りに機械みたいに動く人はどんな失敗するかわからない
それ自分がちょっと上に昇格されたら何もできなくなっちゃうんです
後輩の管理できなくなるんです
そういうわけで このマインドコントロールはもう知らず知らずやってますけど
だから社会でどこを見てもかなり失敗の数が多いんですよ
自分でするマインドコントロール
今言ったのは他人にやっていることですよ
自分でもやってますよ
この自分でやっているものは
一つはこの社会から見るとポジティブ思考の人間だが
何なのかというと 看板だけ気にして
有名な学校に入ってなんとか卒業する
そういうことよくあるでしょうね
やっぱり入るんだったら
有名な学校に入らなくちゃいかんと
あれ 勉強するつもりじゃないんですよ
ただ 学校の名前だけ 資格や免許を駆け集める
駆け集める はい あれこれといっぱいもう駆け集める
何としてでも肩書きやタイトルを取る
タイトルということっていうのは
あんまり日本語 日本では使わないんですけど
タイトルというね いろいろ人にタイトルあるんですよ
そういうのはなんとかして取ろうとするんですよ
出家の世界でもあります
何としてでも取ってやるぞと
有名な大会社に入社する
仕事の場合はもう会社が大きい会社でしょうかとかね
こればっかり探すんですよ
権力者 有名人などとコネを作る
私はあの人も知ってる
この人も知ってるとかね
あるいは誰かの子分になる
そうすると自分に力あると
あると 親分の力なんですけど
そういうことで そうやって力あるところに入って子分になるんです
そのマインドコントロールは自分でやるんです
面白いですよ 自分でマインドコントロールできるということは
次にもまた自分でするマインドコントロール
これから社会から見ると
ネガティブ思考の人間
前のものはみんなほほうかするでしょ
いい会社に入って何が悪いんですかと
東大に入って何が悪いんですかと
私は悪いと言いたいんですけどね
もう勉強したくて研究したくてだったらもう簡単に入りますよ
頭がいいんだったら でも電車の看板見るとそうじゃなくて
ただ単に何でもいいんだから東大に入ることが目的なんです
だから東京大学っていう看板だけなんですよ
それはポジティブ的に社会側はポジティブと言うんだけど
仏教はもうあんまりポジティブと思わないんです
自分が生きる範囲を狭くして
精神的に高い壁を作るんですね
いろいろ精神的な壁を作って
その中にいるんですね
私はあれもやりません
これもやりませんとかね
もういろいろことするんです
人の意見 新しい情報などを無視する
それで自分の生き方に自信を持つ
あれこれと新聞を読んだり
いろんなデータを調べたり考えて
もうそんないらん うるさい
めんどくさいとかね 頭が悪くなるだけだとかね
言ってカットするんですよ
カットしたら自分だけ知ってる情報で
我ながらよく知ってるんだぞとかね
そういうふうなこともしますよ
で 自分に自信を持てるんですね
自分が神様に守られていると信じる
これ結構ありますよ あの戦争に守られているか
もう神様に至っても これはただの一般用語で使った言葉ですけども
自分が守られていると好いているんだと
運がいいんだと いうふうに思ったりする
必死で他人のことを軽視する
見下す これで結構自信過剰になりますよ
人のことなんだ あれぐらいのことはとかね
それはどうったことはないんではないかとか
それで自分の自信過剰生活をもう続けるんですよ
自分に超能力がある 占いなどに頼る
自分にはいろいろ能力がありますと
自分がやったらうまくいくんだとかね
なんかどこかで神秘的に自分に力があるとか思ってるんですね
そういう人々はもうかえって占いとかよく信じる
どうでもいいからたくさんの仲間を作る
これも自分でやる悪いことなんですね
とにかく仲間がたくさんいればいいから
どうでもいいんだから
もう人は選ぶも何もなくて
大勢の人の中でいるんですね
そうするともう自信になります
これはあまり良くないと社会が良くないというもの
それは当然良くないことなんですけど
前にやったものは本当は良くないんです
そうやって自分のマインドコントロールには 2種類あります
それからまたマインドコントロールありますよ
政治 経済 宗教によるマインドコントロール
政治家が愛国心 国のプライドなどの餌を見せて
さらに事実情報を 秘密にして人をコントロールするんですよ
それから 戦争などを引き起こすために権力を
まあ文章間違ってますね
引き起こすために 権力を維持するために
国民を自信過剰にさせる
もうかなり政治家がマインドコントロール
例えばブッシュさんが見事に国民
アメリカ人をマインドコントロールさせて
信じられないほど財産をなくして
たくさんの人を殺して
いまだに続けてやってます
あれは個人的で 自分のためにやってるんですよ
何一つもいい結果がないんだけど
もうやめられませんね
兵隊さんにももう戻れませんし
自信過剰にしているんです
されてるんです だからどんな
例えば北朝鮮にしたっても
もうもう決まってる情報だけ流して
自由という言論の自由なんか発言の自由とか全部もう禁止しちゃって
マインドコントロールしてるんです
それで何かあったら 北朝鮮国民はみんな立ち上がるんですよ
一斉に 何の問題もなく
だから他の国を攻めやすい
このマインドコントロールのせいで
だから私は今日は自信過剰の問題ですけど
例えば北朝鮮の方々っていうのも何もできないんだけど
自信だけは過剰にあるんです
政治家のマインドコントロールのせいで
アメリカ軍隊というのは行ったところでは成功したことはほとんどないんだけど
世界一自信だけはあります
過剰に そういうことで政治家はよく頑張ります
たった半年 これからは経済ですね
たった半年で億万長者になった一般の主婦の神話などを叩いて
人を自信過剰にさせる
この経済世界でも そういう突然億万長者になった話はよく出ます
今は来ないんですけど
前は私のインターネットでも結構スパムメール来てたんですよ
3週間でビリオネアになるんだよと
また証言あるわあるわあるわ
あの人この人とかね そういう風に人間乗っちゃいますよ
で これこれぐらい仕事をすれば
あなた次第でもう月々10万も儲かる
100万も儲かると言うんですよ
それはあなた次第だよと
これを売ってください
で  5万しか 5万円のしか収入ない場合はもう脅すんですね
なんてないのに さんが
そっち 100万売ってますよ
それはごく普通の奥さんだよ
そういうことで 人間も経済世界で
そちらの商売ですけどね
一般人を餌食にするんですね
自分が儲かるんです 自分というのは
この経済活動をやっている人々が
宗教の場合はですね 残ったのは信仰
絶対的な神 永遠の極楽などの餌に餌を餌に出して
自信過剰症に感染させるんです
自信過剰な人々は信仰者の中でもいくらでもいます
餌出されてますからね
それによって宗教組織が財産と権力を得るんです
信者さんには何のこともないんだけどね
戦争 テロ行為 自爆行為などできるまでありがたい自信をつけてくれるんですよ
宗教は 宗教のおかげで平気で自爆テロでもやりますからね
人は自分で死にたくないでしょうに
でも永遠の極楽堂ありますからね
天国あるんだからという風に餌撒いちゃうとやっちゃうんです
信仰の力は最大ですからね
政治にも使用される だから政治活動にも結構宗教を使うんですよ
もうパキスタンやらアフガニスタンやらね
イラクやらそこら辺でもう宗教ですね
政治やっているのは どんな悪いことでもできる
何の人からの民主主義も何もない
もう もう殺生といえばもうものすごい恐ろしい
差別といえば でも誰も文句言わない
その代わりにコーラントイレに流したそうと言って泣きながらデモやってます
コーランというのはもうまあ 1万冊ぐらいトイレに流しちゃっても
別に宗教には何の影響もないんですけど
それで神がくたばるんだったらね
まあろくでもない神でしょうに
私が言いたいのは あのイスラムの人々はどれほど仏教を破壊したのかというと
中央アジアは全部仏教でしたでしょうに
シルクロードはアフガニスタン
パキスタン インド 全部壊したのはそういう人々なんです
ナーランダ大学っていうのはそのままもう囲まって焼いちゃったんだから
何千人も坊さん死んだったんですよ
1 日で だからその連中にはいいんですよ
他宗教侮辱するのも何でもかんでも
だからって仏教と別に腹が立ってるわけでもないし
いつでも仏教の人はイスラム教の人を助けてあげたりもするし
国際問題 いろんな場合は
自分の国はいつでもそういう人々のためにしゃべるんです
では 仏教に対してはろくなことをやらないんですよ
我々は知ってるわよ これ何がやったって
仏教は仏教であるよと
武装ぐらい爆弾かけて壊したんだからといって
もうへっちゃらやと まあブッダの言葉書いてる本でもね
向こうは燃やしちゃったら
私たちは別な本買いますからね
で 燃やされたらそちら買わなくちゃあかんだから
自分の本が売れませんだからね
まあ勝手に燃やすんだからやってください
それでお金入りますから
出版社にね だからまあ無知もいいところですよ
それも信仰でマインドコントロールして
すっきりフィクストのないアホにしているんですよ
それで 第1部は終了です
マインドコントロールによって自信過剰症に感染するということは
マインドコントロールは 3種類あります
家族から 周りからマインドコントロールされる
それから自分自身のマインドコントロール
自分でもやる 社会と宗教のマインドコントロールという 3種類あります
それによって人々は自信過剰になるんですね
はい ちょっと休憩いたします